well if you want to get the attention of
the vatican or the leaders of the boy
scouts of america
all you have to do is mention the name
of one american lawyer jeff anderson
rhonda
that's right brian and over his long
career
jeff anderson has taken on thousands of
clients
survivors of sex abuse and received tens
of millions in settlements
from the catholic church the boy scouts
and even the vatican
and now he's on to his next big case
against a widely uh
spattered church in this country the
light of the world church
led by a man who calls himself the
apostle
we are here today standing with social
to sound the alarm
and to expose the culture
and the predators that are active as we
speak
not just in trafficking not just
in sexual assault not just in the
cover-up of it
but in the silencing of anybody that
would speak against them
i have never ever in the 38 years i've
been in this work been more alarmed
about the safety of children
than in this situation for the first 30
years of my life
i was taught to believe that my body my
mind
my soul belonged to mundo
because it was the will of god
from the age of nine i was taught
that my own family and community
that my eternal soul depended on me
sexually pleasing losing apostles
for nearly 22 years i was made to work
for
travel for life for
and give my body to an organization
that saw me as nothing more than a
source of profit
and sexual pleasure
and we're joined now by jeff anderson
from his office and jeff thank you much
for being here tell us a little bit
about social martin
and why you think this case is such a
important one
what an extraordinarily courageous
woman courageous survivor
and i say that because she is one
of many thousands now
who not only have shared the secret of
sexual abuse
and exploitation but she
has chosen and had the courage to stand
up not just for herself
but to stand up against a very
powerful religious organization
called the light of the world alolus del
mundo
and its so-called apostle
who exercises enormous power
and against that power she has shined a
light
i having brought suit by having
shared her secret and had the courage
to tell the truth and thus shine the
light
so that other kids can be protected
but an extraordinary woman who is among
thousands of survivors
with whom i and we have had the
privilege to now
work with for
almost four decades
as you know the apostle nae san joaquin
garcia
has pleaded guilty to more than 20
criminal charges in his awaiting trial
in california why the civil lawsuit now
you're going after the church and him
yeah he's actually pled not guilty
and is awaiting trial and being held
on very high bail as we speak and
the civil suit has been brought by her
and by us because it really
is an opportunity to bring more light
and more truth to what he and those
around him have done to
so many for so long using their power
using their position
to not only exploit children
and vulnerable adults but to allow so
many
else around them to do it
and this civil suit brought by her
and others like her really brings light
and truth to bear
in a way that a criminal case can't
because a criminal case
focuses on the offender the civil
case focuses on the culture that
permits the offender to
engage in the criminal conduct
and the cover-up and concealment of it
and thus the civil suits that both
social martin has brought
and the other survivors with whom we
work bring
and continue to bring really protect
kids in the future
and help those jeff have been hurt
a question for you jeff from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
and jeff you're so well known for the
cases that you brought against the
catholic church
is this are you finding is this a church
or is this a different kind of
organization and are there special
perils here
many of the survivors that we've spoken
to have told us they're very afraid to
speak out
well you know this journey for me
working with survivors began in the
early 80s
and the first suit brought against the
catholic bishops in america
and exposed their concealment
and cover-up of it the case by social
martin
uh parallels uh that uh
effort that began for us almost four
decades ago
but the thing that makes this so
stunning
after all these years is the peril
that is so present in real time
right now and that means that what
he the apostle and that culture
which calls themselves a church that
more appropriately
resembles a cult in any
definition of cult applies here
power concentrated and you think loses
it
why do these cults of this widespread
sexual abuse what's at the heart
of it why do we keep seeing so much
well i think at the heart of this cult
and this particular case
is a concentration of power using
divinity
and using the power
that they have over the souls and the
care of the souls
and in addition they use fear
and they use intimidation and they use
money and with the power
of their divinity and the power
that they enjoy over the souls of these
adults who join them
and they exercise it and they also use
um intimidation all right jeff anderson
thank you so much for joining us
continue to
do the good work you've been doing
that's made your name so well known and
so
feared by people in power jeff anderson
thanks much
thank you you're watching brian ross
investigates on the long crime
trial network